ça va
bonsoir Je m'appelle Claire et si je
suis là devant vous aujourd'hui c'est
parce que j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle à vous annoncer par laquelle je
commence
bon on va commencer par la mauvaise
comme ça ce sera fait
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que les
activités humaines sont sans équivoque
responsable du réchauffement de la
planète ça vous stresse moi en tout cas
ça me stresse et vous inquiétez pas j'ai
la bonne nouvelle
la bonne nouvelle c'est que les
activités humaines sont sans équivoque
responsables du réchauffement de la
planète
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est le GIEC
le Groupe intergouvernemental des
experts sur l'évolution du climat mais
moi j'aime bien me dire que quand on y
pense c'est vrai qu'on adore les mains
nous les humains les cartes du problème
et de la solution alors lorsque j'ai
réalisé ça il y a 5 6 ans j'étais à
votre place étudiante et j'étais déjà
passionnée par la communication plus que
passionné j'étais persuadé que ce serait
tel qui nous permettrait de mettre le
monde en mouvement alors aujourd'hui ce
que j'aimerais c'est vous partager ce
que j'ai appris les bonnes pratiques
pour utiliser la communication pour
mener à bien mes projets d'engagement
pour ça je vous propose qu'on repartira
première vidéo publiée sur Facebook
on assume j'avais j'étais en 2018 je
m'étais filmée en selfie face à un
coucher de soleil tout près du Lac de
Maine à Angers dans une des plus belles
villes de France si vous en doutez
encore
et j'étais persuadé qu'en publiant cette
vidéo sur Facebook ça allait je sais pas
booster des gens et donc là on va pas
très bien sans petit mais il y avait 40
like peut-être sans vue
ceci dit j'ai écouté les conseils j'ai
pas j'ai pas abandonné j'ai réussi d'yvé
je suis passé à une autre plateforme
YouTube à la sortie du confinement j'ai
lancé une émission qui s'appelle les
pépites vertes dans laquelle je présente
des métiers de la transition écologique
j'allais jusqu'à 3000 vues sur certains
épisodes donc un peu mieux et puis enfin
je suis passé à l'offensive sur Linkedin
où là j'arrive avec des contenus qui
font des riches mensuels qui vont
jusqu'à 170
000 vues sur mes contenus ok très cool
au-delà de ces stats qui boostent mon
ego qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ce qu'on en
fait et ce qu'on en apprend c'est qu'en
5-6 ans de création de contenu j'ai
appris à démultiplier mon impact sur mes
communications digitales mais je dois
vous dire quelque chose c'est aussi un
impact que j'ai démultiplié dans mes
communications interpersonnelles dans la
vraie vie
et pour ça j'ai eu la chance de vivre
une anecdote assez significative avec
des membres de ma famille et
alors ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on
se fasse un petit film rétro on se met
une musique d'ambiance on repart en
arrière on est en décembre 2017 c'est
l'hiver la nuit tombe tout je vis mon
réveil écologique je suis bouleversée
par la situation je rentre chez mes
parents je rentre dans la cuisine je
suis chez mes parents je m'approche du
frigo et qu'est-ce que je vois
une scène de crime qu'est-ce que je vois
je vois du plastique je vois de la
viande j'ai même vu un légume
hors-saison je me retourne vers mes
parents je me dis how Thai comment
osez-vous vous rendez pas compte mais
vous êtes complètement irresponsable
quand je leur dis ça je suis persuadé
d'un truc ça va aller les activer quoi
ça marche pas trop
je rigole plutôt de la colère de
l'incompréhension et je finis par
m'excuser parce qu'en fait ce que j'ai
compris c'est que on voulait faire ça je
voulais l'échanger mais c'est pas ça qui
a bien marché c'est pas l'échange et
c'est moi qui ai changé j'ai changé à
tel point que six ans après cette
histoire aujourd'hui les relations sont
apaisées avec mes parents ma maman
m'envoie des photos de ses petits élèves
qui font des marches pour le climat dans
la cour de récré en petite section Mon
papa épreuve de maths et ne va parle
plus qu'Anton équivalent CO2 et moi
j'avoue il y a un peu de plastique dans
mon frigo
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé comme je
vous le disais c'est moi qui ai changé
j'ai changé ma manière de parler j'ai
changé ma manière de raconter j'ai
changé ma manière d'un carnet et ce soir
j'aimerais vous partager trois petites
techniques qui m'ont permis de mener à
bien à chaque fois un peu plus avec un
peu plus d'efficacité tous mes projets
d'engagement grâce à la communication
ces trois petites techniques la première
c'est de savoir associer la raison à
l'émotion la deuxième c'est de pouvoir
adapter son discours aux personnes à qui
on parle et la troisième c'est de ne
jamais rien faire sans formaliser une
intention
alors je sais que je suis dans une
maison ingénieur et qui la raison prône
sur les émotions ceci dit j'ai réalisé
au fur et à mesure de mes communications
que pouvoir allier des faits des
solutions des exemples des petits pas
concrets à l'humilité de partager des
émotions par exemple de la peur de
l'anxiété mais aussi de l'enthousiasme
et de l'espoir permettent vraiment de se
donner beaucoup plus de chances de
réussir à faire passer le message aux
audiences on arrive donc à mon deuxième
point à qui on parle à qui on parle à
qui on s'adresse quels sont les usages
des personnes à qui on a envie de
s'adresser dans quel bout de leur
quotidien on rentre je vais vous donner
un exemple très concret je suis
entrepreneuse et j'ai eu la chance par
exemple en janvier dans la même semaine
de pouvoir intervenir devant des lycéens
des lycéens ou devant des ministres et
la première ministre
autant vous dire que j'ai pas fait les
mêmes blagues et que j'ai pas préparé de
la même manière mon discours parce que
vraiment mon point c'était de m'adresser
aux personnes de rentrer dans leurs
références d'utiliser leurs imaginaires
pour les embarquer avec moi dans
l'histoire que je voulais le partager
et puis enfin je l'ai mis à la fin mais
j'ai fait un peu exprès pour qu'on passe
du temps dessus je pense que c'est
impossible de réussir une communication
sans avoir formalisé une intention
claire qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
de ce message que vous allez partager
qu'est-ce que vous voulez générer chez
les gens qu'est-ce que vous voulez les
faire activer est-ce que c'est juste
partager une information ou les aider à
passer à l'action ou leur faire
ressentir des choses si on reprend mon
exemple du frigo là quand je suis
arrivée en mode ouvrez police du climat
Greta senberg à mes parents d'après vous
c'était quoi mon intention il y en avait
pas il y en avait pas assez normal
potion de peur de colère et c'est OK
quand on a des projets qui nous tiennent
à cœur c'est normal de ressentir ses
émotions la question c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on en fait où est-ce qu'on met cette
énergie
et moi je suis créatrice de contenu et
ma passion s'est raconté les coulisses
alors aujourd'hui ce que je voudrais
c'est vous partager le secret que j'ai
utilisé cette technique ces trois
techniques pour préparer cette éx
effectivement l'intention pour moi
c'était vraiment de venir sur scène ici
pour vous donner les outils très
concrets et activables vous donner
l'envie de sortir de cette salle de
prendre votre téléphone et de rappeler
cette personne avec qui vous avez pas
réussi à bien interagir il y avait une
autre intention cachée que je dois vous
partager c'était réussi à rester
moi-même alors j'espère à la fin que je
me dirais que j'ai réussi ça
pour l'adaptation vous avez regardé j'ai
je me suis adressée aux étudiants et
étudiantes ingénieurs je me suis
adressée à des personnes qui peut-être
comme moi avaient des projets qui les
tenaient à coeur tout en étant vigilante
parce que mes conseils soient assez
génériques pour que tout le monde puisse
les prendre dans sa propre valise
et puis enfin raison et émotion j'ai
veillé à mélanger des exemples concrets
des solutions et à vous partager mon
enthousiasme ma peur parfois mais
surtout mon grand sens de l'espoir parce
que si je suis là devant vous c'est
parce que j'y crois encore et ce que
j'aimerais vous partager vraiment c'est
vous rappeler que lorsqu'on parle de
communication il ne s'agit pas seulement
de se demander de quoi on parle mais
aussi de comment on le dit et surtout de
pourquoi aussi j'aimerais vous inviter à
ne jamais sous-estimer le pouvoir d'une
intention bien racontée sincère pour
faire changer les choses merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]